elected leaders in Washington State may
crack down on vaccine exemptions amid a
growing measles outbreak lawmakers are
proposing a bill that would no longer
allow parents to cite philosophical or
personal reasons for not vaccinating
their child currently 18 states allow
those exemptions and Carter Evans is at
the State Capitol in Olympia where a
public hearing will take place today
Carter good morning good morning the
governor has declared a state of
emergency here as the number of measles
infections continues to rise there are
now 56 cases here in the Pacific
Northwest and lawmakers are hoping to
pass a bill that will insure more
children are vaccinated right now my
city is the hotbed for this outbreak
monica Stonier is the state
representative for Clark County
Washington the area hardest hit by the
measles outbreak in her County alone
there are currently 51 confirmed cases
of measles and another 13 suspected it
certainly has reached a critical stage
in my County Stonier is now
co-sponsoring a bipartisan House bill
that would require every child at every
public and private school in the state
and licensed daycare center to be
vaccinated for measles mumps and rubella
unless they have a legitimate medical or
religious exemption if you would have
asked me four years ago I would have
told you that yeah every child needs
their axons Abigail Lockhart refuses to
vaccinate her youngest child she says
it's because her middle child suffered
significant behavioral and physical
reactions after being vaccinated
including severe eczema and food
allergies if I could go back I wouldn't
have vaccinated any of my kids
according to the CDC most people who get
the vaccine do not have any serious
health problems the agency also says for
every 1000 children who get the measles
one or two will die from it the benefits
of the vaccine greatly outweigh the
risks dan Salman is the former director
of vaccine safety for Health and Human
Services
he said measles can cause lifelong
complications no one knows that better
than Cecilia Rodriguez in 1989 she was
too young to be vaccinated when she
contracted the German measles I can end
it for me it became a lifetime
Rodriguez spent nine months in a coma
and almost died thirty years later her
eyesight speech and hearing are still
affected I do not want to go through
that experience with my three three
beautiful children that I have Salman
says in a way vaccines are a victim of
their own success because most people
have never seen the measles people
aren't afraid of what they don't know
and we'd like to keep it that way
people on both sides of the issue are
expected to speak at what could be a
very fiery hearing today lawmakers are
hoping to determine if they have enough
votes to move forward gale we shall see
Thank You Carter